we are asked to estimate what is 2.7
times 4
roughly equal to pause this video and
see if you can answer that
all right so we could think of 2.7 times
4 as being roughly equal to or some
people might say as approximately equal
to
let's see 2.7 that's two ones and seven
tenths we could think about well what's
the nearest whole number to 2.7 and so
2.7 is pretty close to 3. it's in fact
closer to 3 than it is to 2. so we could
say that this is roughly equal to 3
times 4
and then 3 times 4 is of course equal to
12. and you can see that these other
answers actually seem quite unreasonable
1.2 if i take something and i multiply
it times 4 i shouldn't get an answer
that is less than my original something
and then to go from and then to take
something that's roughly equal to three
times four to get to 120 that doesn't
make sense it definitely doesn't make
sense to get to 1200. let's do another
example
so here where say we said what is
roughly equal to 78 times
19.88
so pause this video and try to answer
that
all right well this is really the same
idea we want to think about what are
numbers that these numbers are close to
that are easy to multiply with so for
example 78 that is pretty close to 80
and then
19.88 or 19 and 88 hundredths that's
pretty close to 20. it's closer to 20
than it is to 19 and even if it was
closer to 19 just to estimate i probably
would still go to 20 because it's easier
to multiply with 20. so this is going to
be pretty close to 20. so all of this is
going to be roughly equal to 80 times 20
and you might already recognize that
this is going to be 8 times 2 times 10
times 10
and i could write it that way actually
no reason for me to skip steps but you
would normally do this in your head so
80 is the same thing as 8 times 10. let
me do that in that purple color so you
can see it so this is the same thing as
8 times 10
times
times 2 times 10 which we could then
write
this is
going to be
8 times two which is sixteen
so the eight and the two
you get sixteen times ten times ten is
times one hundred so this should be
sixteen hundred
sixteen hundred which is
this choice right over here it's always
good to just do a reality check to make
sure it's reasonable it wouldn't make
any sense if i take a number close to 80
and i multiply it sometimes some number
that's close to 20 and get a smaller
number than 80.
it also if you have a number that's
close to 80 to get 160 you'd only have
to multiply it by roughly two but here
we're multiplying by roughly 20 and then
to go from 82 or roughly 80 to 16 000
well then you wouldn't have to multiply
by something that's close to 20 you'd
have to multiply something that's close
to 200 so i like our answer